we are still not over ariana grande
bringing out in sync as she headlined
Coachella it's the reunion fans have
been waiting for for this moment
et has exclusively learned the epic
performance on Sunday all quote came
together very last minute according to
our source ariana and her manager
Scooter Braun reached out to JC Shaw's
A's manager just one week before after
the conversation JC delivered the news
to the other members of in sync and the
guys were quote immediately on board oh
my god dis look everything now everyone
but Justin Timberlake made it to the
music fest he wasn't there because he
was on his own tour but shared he was
having a little FOMO with this pic and I
do not blame him for that FOMO because
this was everything but we can only
wonder what he have made it had he had
more than weeks notice I feel like he
would have there's rehearsals involved
if you're traveling you need to get on
the flight
he may have made it if they had a little
more time
[Music]
Ahri's practice definitely paid off on
stage just days before fans speculated
the singer might be hinting at an NSYNC
cameo later set after she posted a
series of throwback videos singing and
dancing to the old 90s classic yeah I
feel like she brought those dance moves
re and NSYNC teased fans even more on
Twitter Thank You next singer replied to
this tweet from JC before re chela that
read Mic Check Mic Check one two is this
thing on and re wrote sure is they wrote
dangling the carrot and then they
delivered and the good news for fans
this may not be the last re NSYNC collab
our source says Ari and JC talked
backstage after the show and said quote
they should do another project again in
the future okay we can't wait to see how
this all shakes up for all the latest in
pop culture be sure to subscribe to all
things et until next time I'm Courtney
teza know and I'm Holly Stevens bye for
now
[Music]